the magnate eppadi the statement is an
ideal exhibition space for contemporary
artists such as Mauricio Catalan of
Italy his Novecento taxidermy horse
hangs over the entrance the artist
himself breaks through the parquet floor
below this is a very important work as
it represents Maurizio Cattelan and the
way he's broken into the art world like
a thief and he himself is completely
surprised that's very characteristic of
his work he deals quite a lot with
failure and the problems associated with
success this portrait shows Catalan at
age 25 born in Padua in 1960 he came
from modest beginnings and settled in
New York City in the early 1990s he made
his name internationally with his
hyperrealist often satirical figures
Maurizio Cattelan hanging on the wall is
always comical and light-hearted but
it's also an insightful portrait look at
his gaze one of his famous horse
installations is also on view it
represents power it's a horse very
typical of equestrian statues but
there's no warrior astride and the horse
has no head it's a critique of authority
and the abuse of power
in what his best-known works ix our
Catalan brains a meteorite down on Pope
John Paul the second the ninth hour
alludes to the part of the gospel where
Jesus is on the cross and feels
abandoned by his God it's a deeply
spiritual work
it's one of Catalans obsessions is
religion as an instrument of power he
likes to shock people if it had been
nothing more than a provocation nobody
would pay attention to it now 20 years
later much like Oscar from Gunter
glasses the tin drum Catalan rejects the
hypocritical world of adults his
creations are forever in search of a
spiritual father figure